hey hey mind if i interrupt you just ask
what you're reading i can clearly see
the title of the book i just want to
engage you in social interaction even
though everything about your body
language says you'd rather die than have
a conversation with me
hi how's it going hey i don't really
have anything to say i just kind of need
constant approval and validation you
know what i mean
i just want to read oh no problem talk
to you later trump
am i right i feel like this guy's just
like crazy orange man you know
is he still pretty you know i really
rather read oh that's cool that's cool
my wife makes me sleep in a motel how's
it going i gotta say timothy oliphant
very underrated actor fire oh my god
there's a fire i'm just kidding i'm just
really needy
hey did you read that piece in the new
yorker i didn't either so
dolphins are a thing i'm still reading
yeah no problem i don't know how many
times i have to tell you this
atlantis is not a real place oh you're a
different person sorry so me and the
boys are thinking of going to laguna
beach or malibu for the fourth i was
kind of partial to looking at a beach
because last time i wasn't malibu
they were at the same page 10 times must
not be a very good book then
am i right so i was thinking malibu
because last time i was on lagoon beach
things got kind of crazy i killed a
stripper
[Music]
weird